it's been an interesting week i think um
i don't know about you but i think i
could do with some more sleep
i know however moving on to the agenda
we do have a shared agenda and about how
we can build a better berry for all
those who need it the most
and it's a great honor if not a surprise
to be here today
yesterday i said that britain needs a
government
focused on tackling the cost of living
crisis and providing a path out of a
global pandemic
that path needs to protect living
standards it needs to defend security
for all
that's why i joined the labour party
[Applause]
because only labor are coming up with
the solutions
the conservative party aren't even
talking about the problem let alone
offering solutions and here on the front
bench right now we have someone not only
talking but offering a fully costed
solution and we're all looking forward
to hearing more from you rachel
families businesses and pensions here in
berry and across the country
really need leadership with key li with
kyostama we are getting
real proper leadership with integrity
and respect the labour party is firmly
back in the center of british politics
it's in touch with working people and
ready to provide an alternative
government that this country can be
proud of and deserves
and certainly not to be embarrassed by
and that is one of the reasons why i'm
here today
i will always put the people who bury
berry cell first and i look forward to
working with andy
eamon and labor colleagues locally and
nationally to achieve the needs of this
area
changes that i believe can be best
delivered with the labour government led
by kia slama
since becoming shadow chancellor rachel
has shown labour is the party of
economic competence once again
i know labour's plan for growth and the
stronger economy is what we need here in
bury and across the country